this is goliath a galapagos tortoise  he is massive  at over 520 pounds he's one of the  biggest tortoises in the world  goliath is believed to be in his 80s  galapagos tortoises have been known to  live over 150 years  they can go extended periods of time  without food or water  up to a year  this unfortunately led to human  exploitation  sailors on ships would bring these  slow-moving defenseless giants on long  voyages as a source of meat  by the 1970s only about 3000 were left  but through conservation and breeding  efforts there are now over 20 000  they've become a flagship species for  conservation efforts throughout the  galapagos  but poaching and habitat loss are still  a very real threat  this is the galapagos tortoise